In today's video,
we're revisiting something
we've tested in the past.
What happens if you
take all of the moisture
out of soda, specifically,
is it different
from regular soda,
soda made with cane sugar,
and soda made
with artificial sugar?
[Music]
Guys, while back,
we did a test where we
tried to take Coca-Cola,
and we dehydrated it.
We put it in
our homemade dehydrator,
and we let it run
for several days.
The result we got was
a sort of thick syrup
that was a very
concentrated flavor.
I had several people request
in the comments
something like this,
that we try out
using Mexican Coca-Cola,
which is supposed to be made
with cane sugar rather than
high fructose corn syrup.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got normal Coca-Cola,
Mexican Coca-Cola,
and diet Coca-Cola,
and we're going to compare
all three by heating them up,
dehydrating them,
and freeze drying them.
This particular comment
from YouTube user
useazebra also suggested
that we try dehydrating
our Coca-Cola in low pressure,
or freeze dry.
Well, we now have
a freeze dryer,
and I did think it was a cool
idea to test the difference
between the high
fructose corn syrup
and the cane sugar
types of Coca-Cola.
And while we're at it,
I also got some Diet Coke.
I've got some frying pans,
and we can try heating
them up on a stove.
That'll be a really quick way
to try and get all
the moisture out.
We've got our dehydrator,
the homemade Dehydra-Tron 5000.
So we're going to try
all three types of this soda
using those methods.
The American Coke has
high fructose corn syrup,
the Mexican Coke has cane sugar,
and the diet coke has
an artificial sugar
called aspartame.
We are also going to do
some side-by-side taste test
to see what the difference is
between all these,
and in fact, we're going to see
if I can taste the difference
between these two
if I don't know
which one I'm drinking.
Standard Coca-Cola.
[Music]
Okay.
There's a bottle opener, right?
Mexican Coca-Cola.
[Music]
I'm not sure if those tasty
differently or not.
Diet Coca-Cola.
[Music]
I don't know.
To me that was pretty similar--
Oh.
Except I'm now
getting the aftertaste
from the aspartame
in the diet Coca-Cola.
So that's something that I
find particularly unpleasant.
So first, we're going to put
these in identical frying pans,
same amount of liquid
in each one,
and we're going to see
what happens to them
as we boil off all the water.
Here we go.
This is our standard Coca-Cola.
[Music]
Got it on the stove,
and the stove
is set too high.
Let's see what happens to this.
I've got two more frying pans.
So we're actually going
to leave whatever's left
in the frying pan.
So we can do a side-by-side
comparison of all three.
It's pretty crazy.
As the water boils off,
it gets more concentrated.
Some of these bubbles
are getting really big.
Like I've seen bubbles that are
three or four inches in diameter
before they pop.
I actually thought
that I would see less
and less of the bottom
as it boiled.
I thought maybe you'd
for more of a skin
or coating on the bottom,
but I'm seeing through
to the white pan more and more
as the water boils off.
Then there's less volume,
so that makes sense.
I just hadn't quite anticipated
what it was going to do
as it boiled.
It's been about
7-8 minutes going,
and I'm smelling just
a little bit of burning.
Okay, regular Coke finished.
Mexican Coke on now.
[Music]
Think about where we
stopped the other one.
There's no more steam
coming off of it.
[Music]
Well, we've got one more pan.
One more type of cola.
[Music]
Our diet Coke is, I think,
just about finished,
and it's behaving much
differently than the other two.
Since it doesn't have
any real sugar in it,
it's-- it really
is reacting differently.
Before, we were getting
bigger and bigger bubbles,
and then it started
finally dissipating away.
But we still had quite a bit
of material in it.
This is now dried up,
and I'm frankly just baffled by
what I see here.
This is super weird,
and not what I
expected at all.
I thought we were going to have
something like the other two.
This is super surprising.
I did not see this coming.
I had no idea this
was gonna happen,
and so, let's talk
about what did happen.
The first two,
one which has plenty
of high fructose corn syrup,
and one of which
has plenty of sugar,
really left quite a bit behind.
The high froctus corn syrup,
this is kind of interesting.
We have a very
thick liquid here.
It is still liquid.
You can see I can push
it around really easily.
The one from the sugar,
I could push it,
and then it just sort of stays
where I left it.
Whereas this, I push it,
and then it just
puddles immediately.
The high fructose corn syrup
has a liquid sweetener in it,
whereas the Mexican Coca-Cola
has a solid sweetener,
cane sugar in it.
And so, when we extract
all the extra liquid,
what we're left
with is liquid over here,
and not so liquid over here.
Very surprising to me
though is the fact
that the Diet Coke ended up
with almost nothing.
There's so little left.
All right, taste test.
Concentrated, and possibly
slightly burned Cola syrup.
Here we go.
[Music]
Ho!
Yeah, concentrated is right.
Wow.
Let's move on to the kind
made with sugar.
[Music]
Pretty similar flavor.
Similar to that one.
I get a lot more of the tang
than I did before.
This one I think has also
caramelized a little bit.
There's real sugar in this,
and I think cooking it
that high temperature
when all the water was gone,
it start to get a little bit
of caramelization.
It's not bad.
I'm going to try
to lick the pan.
See if I can taste anything.
Oh, man.
Oh, that's so bad.
These spots here,
where it's not just splatter,
there's actually like
kind of a puddle,
is very very concentrated.
Just came with a kick
of that aspartame
artificial sugar flavor.
So that was quite unpleasant.
It's really really strong.
It doesn't get
to you immediately.
So I was like licking it
for a couple of seconds,
really wasn't getting much,
and then all of a sudden,
just a wave of that flavor.
I think we need to try
a couple more things.
We've got our dehydrator,
and we've got a freeze dryer.
We want to put some of each
of these into those as well.
Let's get it set up.
[Music]
There. 55.05.
That's close enough.
All right.
55 grams of our diet.
That's gonna do it.
[Music]
All three types of Coke
have now been dehydrated
and freeze-dried,
and the results are
pretty fun to see.
We have lost, of course,
just so much moisture.
Let's take a look.
Our regular soda.
This was 55 grams.
At 7.4 grams,
that means we've lost
47.6 grams of water.
Let's do the same test
with our Mexican Coke.
I was pretty careful
to make sure I had 55
of each of these.
So, this one, 7.75.
Very very close.
We have 0.35 grams,
very little difference
between the Mexican
and the regular Coke.
Let's take a look at the diet.
Just first, let's
look at this cup.
Like there is almost
nothing in there,
compared to the regular,
which is full of syrup.
It is now barely registering.
This is within like the margin
of error of the weight between
two different cups 0.05 grams.
Easily less than one percent
of the mass is left
after all the water is removed
from our diet soda.
That's pretty crazy.
I'm just gonna do a quick
taste test of all of them.
Here's the regular.
This is with the high
fructose corn syrup to start.
[Music]
Very powerful.
Similar to when we boiled it,
although there's no burned
to taste to it.
So it's a little bit
nicer, very sweet.
It's quite tart.
I like it actually.
All right.
Here's the Mexican Cola.
[Music]
Very very similar.
In my head,
I think maybe it has
more of a sugar flavor
that could just be
a confirmation bias,
because I know it has
real sugar in it.
But it's got the cola flavor.
It has the sugar flavor.
It has that tangy flavor.
It's very strong.
Diet.
Now, I'm not even sure
how to taste this
because there's really
hardly any liquid in it.
Looks like I scrape it
off the bottom of burnt pan.
See what this tastes like.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Okay.
That is disturbingly sweet.
Aspartame is approximately
200 times sweeter than sugar.
Well, because there's
not much in here,
when I scrape up just
a finger full of this,
I'm getting like 200 times
the concentration of sweetness,
and that is really powerful.
There's a little bit of liquid,
and then a little bit
of the solid stuff,
and just scrape it
off on your finger,
and then---
Do I even wanna know what this is?
It's literally freeze
dried Diet Coke.
That's mostly aspartame.
Oh, I thought we were friends.
Isn't that like a kick?
It would make
a really good candy
>> if it was like 1/8 of that sweetness.
>> Try the Mexican one,
because that's
just actual sugar.
That's freeze-dried Mexican Coke
made with cane sugar.
It's much more pleasant.
[Music]
So this is mine now.
It's not bad.
No, no. No, no.
I like this one.
Now, we've also
got the ones that we put
through the dehydrator,
and I gotta say, it looks
like we've got pretty much
the same thing going on.
We've got some slightly
runny syrups going on here.
It's actually pretty thick,
that maybe the additional heat
from the dehydrator
as opposed to the freeze dryer.
It may have burned
off a little bit,
and even started
to cook it a little.
So I've got some flakes.
This is our Mexican soda.
[Music]
Really sticks to
your teeth a lot.
Pretty much the same.
Yeah, it tastes like Cola,
a definite tang to it.
Smell is not very powerful,
and it's not a liquid
so there's going to be
less coming off of it.
So that's not too surprising.
The regular soda made
with the high fructose
corn syrup is much more liquid.
Being a liquid,
it doesn't get as solid.
And then, we have our diet,
which is just gone.
There's residue down
at the bottom,
completely dried up.
There's just nothing to it.
I'm going to add water
until this gets
up to 136 grams, and see
if it reconstitutes it all.
I already see it's getting
a little bit of the color.
Start to swirl around a bit,
pulling that color
and flavor off of the bottom,
where it's turned into a solid.
Let's try and encourage
this a little bit.
It looks like we've now pulled
everything off of the bottom.
Now, I'm going to give
this a little taste,
and see how it taste
compared to a normal diet Coke.
I think it looks a little
bit lighter in color,
but not much.
This is a fairly thin layer
on a reflective surface.
[Music]
It seems weak.
Like it seems like it's
missing a lot of the flavor.
I don't know where
that would have gone,
because it should have all
just stayed down in here.
Unless there are other chemicals
that evaporate with the water
in our diet Coke.
Diet Coke versus Mexican Coke
versus regular Coke.
A lot of people had been asking
to see what would happen
if you did it
with sugar cane Coke
as opposed to the high
fructose corn syrup kind.
And while it did harden
up quite a bit more,
neither with the freeze dryer
nor dehydrating it did it
fully turn into a solid.
We can't turn this
into a powder.
I can dig my finger
down into it.
I can stretch it out.
You can see that it
forms these strings.
So it's not something that's
going to turn into a powder,
but it does get closer than
the high fructose corn syrup.
Surprisingly to me,
the diet coke actually
does completely turn down
into something dry and powdery.
So concentrated that it's
like almost offensively strong
if you taste it,
and then adding
water back into it,
I didn't really think
it had all the flavor.
Something got lost in there,
and of course,
it's not carbonated
the way we mix it up here.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
is going to take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you're never going
to miss a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.